for as long as I can remember I've
looked the same short and brown with
really big poofy hair I was pretty much
the same as any other kid in my school
except all the other girls had long
smooth straight hair when I watch TV
everyone else also had a long straight
hair that seemed to flow down their
backs like waterfalls the kids at school
would laugh and call me names like
poodle head or a big hair it got me
thinking maybe I should look like them
too so one day I decided to change I got
up one morning for school and flat
ironed my wild curls until they were
tame and manageable I actually felt
pretty happy with the result
I went to school that day feeling
amazing but of course it rained and by
the end of the day I had the same little
hair again I could hear all the kids at
school snickering that night I sat at
the dinner table and said mom I want a
perm we went to the salon the next
morning they washed my hair and covered
it with this thick smelly cream then I
sat there for what felt like hours I
could feel it stinging and burning at my
scalp but I told myself just ignore the
pain it'll all be worth it they finished
and just like that my hair was smooth
and flat perfect it was exactly what I
wanted but it didn't feel like it was
mine my wants long and bouncy curls now
fell against my face like thin lifeless
strings I gave myself some time to get
used to it but in that time some of my
hair began to shrivel and fall away I've
never been so mad at myself I gave up
something that made me unique just so I
could look like everybody else
eventually my hair grew back and so did
my courage I realized that no matter how
my hair looked it would never define who
I was
it was just hair and when I was all gone
I was still me I've still got poufy hair
but I embrace it every day because it's
mine